صاعقه لامست قيمه برج سي ان في تورنتو
واضاءات معها سماء كندا عاصفه ثلجيه هي
الاسوا منذ 25 عاما حلت على المدنيين
لايام شرقي البلاد
وقتلت معها بعض الاشخاص فيما تركت عشرات
العائلات تعاني من تسمم باول اكسيد
الكربون بسبب اشعارهم الفحم للتدفئه
630 الف منزل غارقه في الظلام ونحو مليون
شخص يعيشون في كنف الطقس القارس ارقام قد
تلخص ما وصل اليه الكنديون بسبب كارثه
جليديه المت بمقاطعتي كيبك وانطاريو
الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان يخرجون من منازلهم
دون ان تثنيهم حبات الثلج عن المكوث في
ديارهم ومن ظلمه البيوت الى المراكز
التجاريه المتنفس المتاح لهم
يجلسون في الممرات والردوهات يتسامرون لا
مكان يؤمن لهم الدفء والكهرباء كما هذه
المراكز نعم ايها الاصدقاء يفترشون
الساحات ريثما يشحنون هواتفهم بصحبه فنجان
قهوه يدفاهم يستلقون هنا وهناك في المشهد
ازدحام لم تعتد عليه كندا نقلا عما تداوله
مستخدموا تيك توك المقيمون في مونتريال
وبين هذه المقاطع تسجل كندا اكبر انقطاع
يطال شبكه الكهرباء في كيبيك منذ العاصفه
الجليديه في العام
1998 التي اغرقت المقاطعه في حاله من
الفوضى لعده اسابيع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات